In the responsive world, choosing
images to suit the viewing context,
art direction can be accomplished
pretty easily with the picture element
to enable display of
a crop of an image or
even a different image depending
on image display size.
Now in this example, we're using
media queries to specify the source.
Full sized kitten for a large view port,
and medium kitten for
a medium view port, and
a small kitten for a small view port.
Cute.
This is doing art direction.
Choosing a different image
with just a few lines of HTML.
Okay, hold onto your hat,
here's the full monty.
We've combined media queries and source
set to specify images for smaller and
larger view ports with different
images for different pixel densities.
Here we get the same effect in Safari,
which doesn't yet
support the picture element.
Well how did we do that?
Well, it's the same markup but
this time we've made use of
the picture fill polyfill.
That's a small JavaScript file that
enables you to use source set and
the other new responsive
image elements and
attributes on browsers that don't yet
support them.
You can find out more about picture
fill from the link below the video.